on en parlait en début d'émission du 23
au 26 février aura lieu la 7e édition du
Mondial d'improvisation junior à Trappes
et ce sont si jeunes Trappistes de tes
clic-tac qui représenteront la France
alors l'année dernière l'équipe junior
de déclicate s'est éclaté deuxième lors
du Mondial d'impro qui avait lieu en
Suisse est-ce que cette année vous
l'appréhendez comment
cette année moi j'ai envie de dire que
peu importe en fait le résultat le
principe ça va être de faire en sorte
que ces 6 improvisateurs trappistes et
en tout cas les trois autres délégations
et des vrais moments de partage dans la
patinoire se découvre découvre leur jeu
et à la fin peu importe le classement en
tout cas pour moi
dans l'ensemble nous ce qu'on veut c'est
faire un bon spectacle pour le public
yvelinois Baptiste donc vous vous avez
déjà participé l'année dernière est-ce
que cette année vous vous engagez
comment l'année dernière c'était quelque
chose d'incroyable je pense que cette
année ce sera pareil mais avant tout
enfin je trouve
[Musique]
au plus vite et que tout se passe bien
dans la patinoire et donc vous aurez
trois matchs donc un face à la Belgique
un face au Québec et un face à la Suisse
c'est ce qu'il y a une nation que vous
redoutez plus qu'une autre
je pense qu'on redoute un peu toutes les
nations mais c'est vrai que le Québec me
fait un peu plus peur pourquoi parce que
l'impro a été créé au Québec ils ont ça
dans le sang ils sont pratiquement nés
avec du coup c'est vrai que j'ai un peu
plus peur mais je pense que ça va bien
se passer et puis on est là pour
s'amuser dans tous les cas donc
est-ce que il y a des manières
d'improviser différemment en fonction de
son pays oui finalement en fait c'est
c'est le rapport à la télé à la
théâtralité pardon à l'humour aussi on
n'a pas le même humour en France en
Belgique Suisse et au Québec et donc
finalement ça fait un joyeux bazar dans
la patinoire le temps de appréhender et
puis surtout ce qui est génial pour
l'improvisateur c'est que c'est que on
est entre déstabilisation
inconfort et plaisir et souvent ça nous
ça nous permet de créer des nouvelles
choses et alors qu'on s'y attendait
vraiment pas donc donc finalement c'est
un inconfort plaisant et vous vous
préparez différemment en fonction des
équipes que vous allez affronter ou pas
vous connaissez un peu leur manière de
jouer pas du tout on est vraiment pas
sur un entraînement sportif où on va
cibler en fonction des attaques des uns
des autres on a vraiment pas nous on est
sur l'approche théâtrale et on fait en
sorte de travail des notions qui vont
être importantes par rapport au public
et par rapport à l'autre qu'on a dans la
patinoire donc le fait de parler fort le
fait de pas refuser une proposition
qu'on nous a donné en face le fait de
toujours être face public
et encore développer un imaginaire en
fonction d'une catégorie donc ça ça oui
on le travaille mais appréhender un jeu
québécois ou un je suis pas du tout en
tout cas pas nous alors comment est-ce
que ça se prépare en fait de
l'improvisation vous avez donné quelques
quelques aspects là mais finalement de
l'improvisation ça se prépare oui et non
on prépare jamais l'improvisation en
elle-même parce qu'on ne sait pas ce
qu'on ce qu'on va jouer on n'est pas
dans le barillet de l'arbitre parce que
je l'arbitre prépare des thèmes des
catégories qu'on ne connaît pas avant
qu'elle soit dites devant le public par
contre ce qu'on fait c'est que ben on se
retrouve de manière hebdomadaire on a un
atelier de deux heures tous les
vendredis dans les locaux de Déclic
Théâtre où là en fait ce qu'on va
apprendre à nos jeunes c'est bah à
partager à accepter le fait de dire oui
finalement c'est une notion pas si
facile le fait de partager son
imaginaire de de laisser aller son
imaginaire parce qu'on a des tendances
un peu à s'auto censurer et finalement
on apprend qu'en impro toutes les idées
sont bonnes à prendre et qu'il y a
jamais de mauvaises réponses il y a de
très bons accidents par contre et alors
est-ce que
j'ai comment comment est-ce que vous
avez été sélectionné pour ce Mondial
d'improvisation
comment on a sélectionné l'équipe de si
j'avais sélectionné l'équipe peut-être
que Baptiste ou non capable au sein de
la compagnie du coup on est 15e
qui organise le Mondial donc il y a une
sélection de trois garçons 3 filles donc
qui du coup pour constituer l'équipe à
l'intérieur de des 14 joueurs et donc
on a su ça il y a un mois et demi
quelque chose comme ça donc trois
garçons trois filles et bah voilà après
c'est nous les coachs donc Alexandra
feignez qui est comédienne aussi a des
qui théâtre et moi même qui sommes les
coachs de l'équipe junior qui avons
sélectionné ces 6 joueurs en fonction de
leur univers de jeu en fonction de aussi
le degré de sociabilité parce qu'on va
pas se mentir c'est une grosse colonie
de vacances sur quatre jours sur les ans
etc et finalement on a on a fait en
sorte que cette équipe soit équilibrée
tant dans la patinoire qu'en dehors de
la patinoire et alors qu'est-ce qui vous
anime en fait dans l'improvisation
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes dit bah je
vais faire de l'improvisation moi j'aime
particulièrement l'impro parce que je
peux changer de personnage durant les
une ou deux minutes d'un pro bah je suis
plus dans le cas je suis quelqu'un
d'autre je suis Émilie je suis Sandrine
et c'est ça que j'aime bien de pouvoir
oublier ses problèmes pour être dans une
patinoire et faire rire le public et
c'est ça que j'aime bien et vous battez
donc moi c'est un peu pareil
au quotidien je suis pas non plus timide
mais ça me permet vraiment de
pour un extérioriser et me faire plaisir
sur quelque chose que pas que j'ai pas
l'habitude de faire c'est à dire que je
me verrais rarement au quotidien je
voulais une princesse en haut d'une tour
et on impro bah tout est possible donc
ça m'est arrivé de jouer une princesse
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé des
catégories du coup là vous avez aucune
idée de des catégories sur lesquelles
vous allez devoir improviser alors si
les catégories on les connaît il y a 15
catégories qui ont été sélectionnées par
la compagnie des clips théâtres et
celle-ci on les a transmises aux autres
équipes pour qu'on puisse tous les
travailler avant le Mondial après on ne
sait pas sur lesquels de ces 15
catégories on tombera ça ce sera à la
surprise chaque soir de spectacle il y a
une catégorie sur Molière où Shakespeare
il me semble exactement on a cette année
on a à la manière de Molière à la
manière de Shakespeare comme vous l'avez
déjà dit on a aussi à la manière des
oeuvres de George Orwell on aura aussi à
la manière d'un numéro de clown ou
encore à la manière avec
l'accompagnement musical donc à la
manière des oeuvres de Charlie Chaplin
finalement ça fait panel très très large
sur lesquelles chacun des 24 joueurs
peuvent trouver chaussures à leurs pieds
et donc trouver un moyen d'expression
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous avez
choisi ces personnalités là ces joueurs
là oui parce que finalement ils étaient
très complémentaires tous les six on en
a on a fait aussi des choix rapport à
des juniors qui l'année prochaine seront
sortants donc c'est à dire qu'ils auront
fini leur cursus avec nous donc histoire
qui vivent en événement important comme
celui-ci et parce que oui c'est un
moment qu'on a envie de partager avec
eux à ce moment-là de leur parcours
Baptiste nanka est-ce que si je vous
demande de faire une petite
improvisation vous êtes partant ou pas
pourquoi pas si je vous demande
d'improviser un JT une émission télé
[Rires]
ou sinon je le mets là-bas c'est
possible de mettre là-bas
on vous laisse vous mettre dans
l'ambiance
faut que je regarde là-bas c'est ça
aujourd'hui
j'ai oublié la date
on est le jeudi 9 février je vais
recommencer
mesdames et messieurs bonjour
aujourd'hui jeudi 9 février nous
recevons Nantes cas aujourd'hui
dans le cas va nous parler de son
travail elle est infirmière et souffre
de difficultés financières aujourd'hui à
cause de covid 19 et de la grève des
transports car elle ne peut plus se
déplacer à son lieu de travail dans le
cas qu'en pensez-vous en effet je n'ai
pas mon permis du coup je ne peux pas
aller en voiture à mon travail ce qui
est très handicapant et la grève a eu un
fort impact dans ma vie car je ne peux
plus aller à mon travail donc je ne peux
plus avoir mon salaire donc je ne peux
plus nourrir ma famille et faire mes
courses et c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé
de moi aussi faire la grève comme ça
s'il n'y a plus de transport il n'y aura
plus d'infirmières
merci dans le cas passons tout de suite
au sujet d'actualité numéro 2 donc
je pense que j'ai plus d'autre chose
pour cette improvisation qui a été
vraiment improvisé comme ça au dernier
moment